[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 78 loisir vos idées
sorties dans le département on commence
tout de suite avec le sommaire de ce
numéro vendredi prochain commence la 19e
édition du festival Jazz à toute heure
dans les Yvelines une quinzaine de
concert jazz et folk auront lieu
jusqu'au 26 mars nous recevrons le
directeur pour nous parler de la
programme formation et si le théâtre
s'invitait dans votre salon c'est en
tout cas l'idée d'une troupe locale
Denis tiison et Catherine Germain
interprètent leur pièce bleu caramel à
domicile plus de détails à suivre et les
vacances touchent à leur fin mais les
activités de la ferme de Gal ell
continuent les weekends Mélanie Pok nous
parlera des ateliers peain pour le faire
soi-même il y aura du football ce
weekend traap affrontera les Gobelins de
Paris l'Étoile sportive 6e du
championnat distance de seulement deux
points le club parisien lui 9e du
classement le match se jouera ce
dimanche à 15h au stade Gilbert chansac
pour soutenir l'équipe locale l'entrée
est libre le président du club de trappe
nous a donné ses impressions avant
l'affrontement on est toujours très
confiant puisque tout repose sur les
entraînements faut savoir que pour une
équipe de PH nous entraînons trois fois
par semaine ce qui est pas le cas de
toutes les équipes de ce niveau très
confiant parce que l'équipe est en place
on a un très bel
effectif et le travail est extrêmement
extrêmement
productif maintenant il faut qu'on ait
des résultats du Lock du break dance ou
de la New Style Le Hipop investit le
prisme d'lancour sous l'impulsion du
chorégraphe ifradia avec ses trois
danseuses il est actuellement en
résidence pour préparer son nouveau
spectacle 3.0 sur le thème de la femme
il sera présenté au public le 21 février
on écoute un Modot d'ifradia au micro de
Mélanie poquet 3.0 c'est le 3è volet
d'int
triptique qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité de mes projets pr je et ISS
de secours avec comme fil conducteur
l'identité je pense que c'est c'est une
pièce qui qui suscite un intérêt qui
questionne qui interroge qui bouscule et
je pense qu'il est nécessaire qu'elle
soit vu par un maximum de de
personnes et c'est maintenant le moment
de parler musique plus pr précisément de
la 19e édition du festival Jazz à toute
heure elle se déroule du 24 février au
26 mars dans la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse et son directeur Michel bocage
marchand est avec nous bonjour Michel
bonjour Camille alors un mot sur ce
festival qui fêtera l'an prochain ces 20
ans d'existence est-ce que quel était
l'objectif initialement quand il a été
créé est-ce que vous imaginiez un tel
succès alors on rêve toujours d'un tel
succès quand on crée quelque chose
l'idée originale c'était la création du
lien social à partir de l'organisation
d'un événement musical en Vallée de
Chevreuse puisqueau départ on était que
sur la vallée de Chevreuse et donc la
rencontre s'est faite avec un parrain
qui s'appelle André searili qui est l'un
des meilleurs batteurs du monde qui
évidemment nous a donné tout de suite
les meilleures adresses et les meilleurs
contact pour avoir les meilleurs
musiciens de jazz et c'est comme ça que
jazz à tout heure est né au départ on un
festival pur jazz on va parler de la
programmation justement parce que ça
commence la semaine prochaine avec un
premier concert à Lévi saintnon alors Pr
concert avec Adou quartet qui est un
groupe qui est plutôt du côté des
musiques du monde avec un mélange entre
des influence orientale africaine
importante et arménienne aussi puisque
dans la dou il y a dou qui vient du mot
doudou qui est un instrument particulier
de l'Arménie et donc c'est une tête
d'affiche pour commencer dans le
festival c'est un groupe qui est très
très connu dans le milieu du jazz et on
est très content c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on les accueille on les on les aime
beaucoup alors vous le disiez un mélange
des genres et je pense que le le
meilleur moyen pour s' rendre rcontre
justement de ce style musical assez
particulier de Adou carartet c'est d'en
écouter un extrait je vous propose d'en
écouter tout de suite un et on se
retrouve tout de suite
[Musique]
après
alors vous l'avez dit ce groupe mélange
plusieurs influences plusieurs styles
musicaux est-ce que justement c'est
représentatif du reste du reste pardon
de la programmation c'est que jazz ou au
contraire on on gravite un petit peu sur
différents courants musical alors au fil
des années jazz à tutter est devenu jazz
à tutter mais pas que avec une
programmation très élargie on intègre du
rock de la chanson française des
musiques du monde du blues aussi du folk
éal du folk aussi donc voilà non on
n'est pas pur Jaz on est on a vraiment
évolué en 19 ans on a évolué vraiment
pour avoir un spectre très très large et
puis évidemment faire plaisir au public
on est dans l'esprit des playlists
aujourd'hui les gens écoutent écoutent
des playlists plutôt que un artiste ou
un joueur en particulier ben voilà on a
calqué ce modèle là sur la programmation
du festival et vous avez des groupes
inédits en France également tout à fait
on a des groupes on est très content
qu'on va accueillir qui vont se produire
pour la première fois en France un
groupe blues rock qui s'appelle Jen le
Hooker il y a un jeu de mot avec JN le
Hooker qui est un grand une grande
légende du blues mais c'est un groupe
uniquement constitué de femmes ce sont
des Américaines qui viennent c'est très
énergique c'est très rock en fait c'est
même encore plus rock que blues ça sera
leur premier concert en France on est
content par ont déjà une réputation
européenne assez importante on
accueillera aussi un duo qui s'appelle
Sarah Jane marice et Antonio Fortunet
Antonio Fortunet c'est un guitariste
qu'on a déjà accueilli dans le festival
mais jamais avec Sarah Jan marice c'est
un nouveau projet c'est l'ancienne
chanteuse des communars donc là on est
plutôt dans la pop musique bon ils ont
un mélange euh assez plutôt blouses en
fait dans l'idée et enfin on fait venir
spécialement de New York le groupe azmat
modine qui est une espèce de c'est pas
vraiment une fanfare ils sont h sur
scène c'est assez burlesque c'est il y a
un côté blues il y a un côté Tom WIS
dedans et ils viennent spécialement pour
nous ça sera leur seul concert en France
cette année on est très fier et un petit
mot sur les tarifs parce que même si
vous avez des des grandes têtes
d'affiche comme vous venez de l'évoquer
il y en a pour tous les budgets voilà on
a deux concerts gratuits un concert
nouvelorléand et puis un concert découp
ouverte le prix moyen c'est 27 € mais le
deuxème concert est à 10 € donc voilà on
fait un effort important pour pouvoir
accueillir le plus de monde possible et
bien sûr faire plaisir le plus possible
pour que ça reste accessible à tous et
bah donc à noter dès maintenant
justement le festival Jazz à toute heure
mais pas que on le rappelle en Vallé de
Chevreuse jusqu'à fin mars toute la
programmation est à retrouver sur le
site internet et merci Michel bocage
marchand pour toutes ces précisions
merci à vous et on va parler de théâtre
maintenant et de l'initiative originale
d'une troupe locale les comédiens jouent
leur pièces chez vous à domicile un
concept lancé en 2011 et qui fonctionne
grâce aux bouche à oreille un reportage
de Nicolas d'Andri et anelur Languille
voici une pièce de théâtre sans théâtre
ce décor n'est autre que le chaleureux
salon d'un couple de Montini le
Bretonneux le temps d'une soirée les
habitants ont accueilli chez eux les
comédiens de la troupe vue sur scène
j'aime jouer chez les gens parce que
c'est une pièce qui est assez intimiste
et donc le décor se prête tout à fait au
au thème de la pièce qui
est une réflexion du couple sur son
dévenir les comédiens de nitison et
ktherine Germain incarnent un couple de
sexagénère au bord de l'ennui alors que
leurs enfants viennent de quitter le nid
familial les laissant seul en face à
face tu es pas contente aujourd'hui si
j'ai envie de passer à autre chose j'ai
peur de
m'ennuyer tu as commencé à
t'ennuyer
oui quand on joue le public est à 3 m
c'estàdire qu'on le sent on sent sa
respiration quoi ça change totalement la
conception du théâtre classique bah
complètement h clos dans un salon cette
pièce intitulée bleu caramel se prête
bien à ce genre d'expérimentation mais
ne vous y trompez pas il y a bien une
mise en scène on utilise le lieu tel
qu'il est
idéalement on se dirait ah ça serait
bien que la cuisine elle soit donc ce
qu'on appelle au jardin au théâtred sur
la gauche de
l'image si elle est à droite ben on fera
avec la droite et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont un petit temps de de répète
sur place pour reprendre leur marque ce
soir-là les fonds ont été reversés à
l'association La cordé francilienne dont
s'occupe Catherine je trouve que c'est
vraiment une idée à à développer à ça
fait passer un bon moment ensemble et
c'est ça sort un petit peu beaucoup même
de l'ordinaire quoi à la fin de la pièce
les comédiens acceptent volontiers de
partager un moment de convivialité alors
n'hésitez plus la troupe se produit dans
toute la
franceère avec du beurre et de la
confiture au petit- déjeuner pendant le
repas à midi ou encore avec de la pâte à
tartiner au goûter le pain est un
élément incontournable de notable et
pourquoi ne pas le faire vous-même
Mélanie poquet s'est rendu dans un
atelier tout spécialement pour les
enfants bonjour Mélanie bonjour Camille
je suis pas allée très loin parce que
j'ai été tout près de 50 ans en Livine
au ferme de G à sincir l'école à chaque
vacan scolair les weekends ou les jours
fériers les équipes proposent un atelier
peain et toute la famille est invitée à
mettre la main à la patte effectivement
parce que dès le plus jeune âge dès 3
ans on peut s'y mettre ça commence à 3
ans on peut le faire jusqu'à ses 12 ans
alors une vingtaine d'enfants peut
participer à chaque atelier ils vont
faire toutes les étapes de la création
de son propre pain l'animateur commence
avec une explication des produits avec
en plus un ancrage local parce que la
farine l'eau et la levure viennent
disciplines c'est important que les
enfants découvent cet ateer là parce que
le pain nous en mangeons tous les jours
on leur fait découvrir les différentes
céréales donc si possible avec aussi du
toucher donc aussi pour découvrir la
matière et aussi surtout de d'où
proviennent les produits qui viennent
forcément de la terre qu'il faut la
protéger aussi il y a pas que la main à
la Pte c'est aussi très important donc
de savoir d'où d'où sont les origines
des produits et l'atelier dure 45
minutes mais ne que la pâte crue en
effet le pain sera cuit à la maison mais
pas d'inquiétude l'animateur remet à la
fin de l'atelier aux parents une recette
notamment à propos de la cuisson mais
lors de cet atelier il y a plusieurs
étapes rigolotes la première bien sûr
c'est de mélanger les produits certains
ont même cru à de la pâte à modeler j'en
ai vu d'autres tenter de goûter avec le
sel c'est pas toujours très bon pas cuit
c'est pas c'est pas ce qu'il y a de
meilleur au goût et puis en rentrant à
la maison il y a une petite étape qui
est super intéressante à regarder c'est
regarder la pâte levée sous l'effet de
la levure avant de la mettre au foid et
ça plaît bien nos enfants écoutez-les
quand on a fait la pâte j'aimais bien il
fallait bien tirer et après il y avait
les trous et après c'est moi j'aime bien
plier après c'est c'était très détendant
maintenant je sais aider parce qu'on a
une machine à à faire du pain et alors
les ateliers ont lieu trois fois par
jour lors des vacances scolaires les
weekends et jours fériers comme je
disais tout à l'heure le tarif 3,80 €
mais c'est toujours le plaisir de goûter
son propre pain et si jamais vous êtes
pas attiré par l'atelier pain il y a
aussi un atelier beurre et d'autres
rendez-vous sont aussi proposés autour
de la nature et des animaux l'occasion
aussi d'en profiter pour visiter la
ferme et ses pensionnaires merci Mélanie
en tout cas de nous avoir parlé de cet
atelier et pour plus de renseignements
rendez-vous sur le site internet et on
passe maintenant à notre agenda avec un
autre rendez-vous à
noter ce lundi les clown de compagnie
gardefous s'invite à la salle de la tour
au programme du rire des larmes de la
poésie et tout cela en improvisation sur
participation du public lundi soir à
20h30 c'est la fin de ce 78 loisir merci
de nous avoir suivi je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
très bon weekend à
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]